i've taken a screenshot from our fill in
the blank proof exercises and i'm going
to work it out essentially on digital
paper and then we can fill in the blanks
on the actual exercise so they tell us
that bc is parallel to df so bc is
parallel to df figure's not drawn to
scale fair enough then they tell us that
angle cef is congruent to angle bac
cef so that's this right over here is
congruent to angle
b a
oh sorry right over here cef is
converted to bac b ac so let's congruent
to that over there
then they tell us that cfe is congruent
to abc angle cfe
cfe
is congruent to angle abc angle abc
all right
then they tell us that segment cf is
congruent to bc
cf
is congruent to bc
all right
then they tell us
that bde is congruent to acb
let's see b d e
b d e is congruent to a c b so that's
that right over there
then they tell us d e is congruent to ac
so d e
d e is congruent to
a c
and then finally they tell us
that b e d is congruent let me do that
in a different color since i keep so b e
d is congruent to b a c b
b let me make sure i get b e d so it's
this angle right over here is congruent
to b d
is congruent to b bac ba sees this blue
one over there so we already have a
marker for that so i'll write the blue
one just like that so that's that piece
of information as well
now we're ready for the proof now
whenever you do any proof it's good to
know what you're trying to prove so
let's just cut to the chase and see
where this proof actually goes so the
last statement of the proof they say
triangle
bca is congruent to triangle bce because
and we have to figure out why we can say
that based on everything that this proof
has proven beforehand but so we're
essentially just proving that triangle
bca
triangle bca which is
which is this triangle
right up here this is bca
that it is congruent to triangle bce
bce is this triangle this kind of
downward pointing triangle so this is
what we're trying to prove this
this is congruent to that right over
here this triangle is congruent to that
triangle so that's important to to keep
in mind and all we know about these two
triangles is that they share a side in
common
which is equal to itself by the
reflexive property but we don't have any
other information we're gonna have to
figure out whether other sides are
congruent or maybe other angles or
something else in order to actually make
this statement so let's see what they've
done in the proof
so first they make a statement and we
don't need to correct it but it's good
to follow the narrative of their proof
bca is congruent to bde
b
c a is congruent to b d e b d a
b d e because of angle side angle so
let's see we have an angle side angle
angle side angle
this triple arc corresponds to d here
corresponds to c there and you see that
even over here the way they wrote it d
is the middle here and c is the middle
there so they do correspond to each
other that makes sense
this angle or sorry the side d e should
correspond to c a and you see that over
here d e corresponds to c a based on the
order it's written e comes right after d
a comes right after c
and so
this seems an angle e should correspond
to angle a and it does angle e
corresponds to angle a and it does so
this is completely legitimate angle side
angle
angle side angle it's a little bit hard
based on how they're oriented it would
have been easier if they're oriented in
the same way but this is legitimate by
angle side angle these two triangles are
these two triangles are congruent
then they say something is equal to
something because corresponding parts of
congruent triangles are congruent and
this is a little bit harder because
they're probably making a statement we
just proved that we just proved that
we just proved that this triangle right
over here is congruent to this triangle
up here and so if we're going to say
that two corresponding things are
congruent it's probably two
corresponding things in these two
triangles and what can we do what what
what is corresponding in these two
triangles that will help us get to our
end goal of saying that this top
triangle is congruent to this bottom one
well the only information that the side
triangle right over here b that bde
shares with the central triangle is the
side so maybe we can say that this side
corresponds to some side up here
and it does because they're congruent
and then that'll give us information for
this middle triangle so let's let's just
think about that and it may or may not
be right but it's a good working it's a
good working guess and there's different
ways to tackle these
so
this side over here b e
b e if we look at how this is b e should
com correspond to b a
b e
remember it's between the blue and it's
between the blue and the not triple
green side so between the blue and the
not triple green side
so these two should correspond based on
the information right over here so this
thing
let me do this in a different color
this thing
this thing should be congruent to that
thing right over there and that gives us
interesting information because now
we've built up two congruent sides of
this middle one and this top one so
let's write that as our as our working
thesis of what they want here so we can
say
we can say b e
b e
b e is congruent
or we could say well we could say the
length is equal but we could even say b
e is congruent
to
b a
is congruent to b va
because corresponding parts of congruent
triangles are congruent this is not an
easy thing to do but the real hint is
they just told us that these two things
are congruent and we want some
information about this middle triangle
and they share a common side here so it
seems reasonable enough all right
hopefully that gets the right endpoint
now they tell us that triangle bca
triangle b
c a
is congruent to f c e
f
c e and we started f we started at b
that's the double angle side then you
went across this one side and you went
across this side with the magenta marker
so that seems right because of angle
angle side
angle angle side
angle blue angle double magenta angle
and then the single magenta side angle
angle side angle angle side that seems
legitimate and it should unless there
was some type of error in this code
and then they say
and then they say ac is congruent to ce
because so ac is congruent to ce well we
just figured out
we just figured out that this top
triangle is congruent to this one down
over here so it's probably going to be
because of corresponding sides of
congruent triangles and we can verify if
this is congruent to that then let's see
ac
is
ac is between is between the blue angle
and the non-magenta angle and ec is
between the blue angle and the
non-magenta angle i haven't marked it
here and so we have ac
ac is indeed congruent to
is indeed congruent to
ce is indeed congruent to ce
and now this is interesting because we
now show that this top and this was
useful because this shared a side with
this middle triangle that we care about
and so we now show this top triangle all
the sides have the same length as all
the sides down here and so now we can
say so this was actually useful
information that we figured out so i
think that's that was the right way to
go about it but now oh i need to finish
this ac is congruent to ce ac is
converted to ce because
corresponding parts of corresponding
angles so i'll just write chorus let me
write in black
and when we actually fill it in we can
there'll be a pull down so corresponding
corresponding parts
bonding parts
and then finally we're in the home
stretch we're ready to say that bca this
top triangle is congruent to triangle
bce all their sides are the same so this
is side side side
side side side congruency so now let's
verify our answer so let's take out
the actual
exercise
and so let's go down here
and so first i need to type in
the first thing i want to type in is
that be is equal to ba
so let me type that in b e is equal to b
and if this is right it'll actually just
it'll just process it is equal to b
a and it is there you go b be or segment
b is congruent to a b and so that's how
we know that we got that right i wrote
it as ba but that's the same thing and
that's why it processed it
and then ac is converted to c because of
corresponding parts
because of corresponding parts
there you go
and then finally these two triangles are
congruent because of side side side side
side side congruence and now let's
verify
let's verify our answer
that's where i feel good about it and i
am ready to check my answer yes it is
correct